now we are taking you back to India and
that breaking news out of the capital
where India's upper house of parliament
has passed a controversial citizenship
bill that will allow minorities who face
religious persecution from neighboring
Pakistan Bangladesh and Afghanistan to
be eligible for citizenship so long as
they're not Muslim let's go to our
reporter and shall Vora she is joining
us live from New Delhi so the bill has
passed as expected anshel absolutely it
was always clear that the bill will sail
through even through the upper house it
sailed through lower house day before
comfortably and now it has been passed
even in the upper house which means that
now there is a legislation in India
called
the citizenship amendment bill which
will ensure that religious minorities
but only from six religions Hindus Sikhs
[ __ ] Jane's Parsees and Christians
from Afghanistan Pakistan and Bangladesh
can claim Indian citizenship provided
they can prove that they were
religiously persecuted in these
countries but it excludes Muslims and
that's the big one here why exclude
Muslims this bill has been described as
discriminatory by many political
observers by many analysts journalists
and of course also the politicians from
opposition parties and Muslim activists
and opposition leaders as well they say
that why has the government not included
the persecuted Rahim Jia in the Myanmar
why have they not included the
persecuted thumb is even though they are
Hindu from Sri Lanka they say that the
government is trying to look for an
explanation when it only includes
persecuted minorities in the three
countries which happen to be Muslim
majority they say that when you exclude
Muslims it has a long lasting impact on
the social fabric of the country because
it has to be seen in conjunction with
the National Register of citizens which
the government has already gone through
in the state of Assam that's essentially
a list of who is and is not an Indian in
the state of Assam now when that is done
across India as is the government's plan
then it will be easier for Hindus to
claim citizenship but not for the Muslim
this
is the fear of for many opposition
leaders and there is a palpable sense of
fear in the areas where Muslim Indian
citizens live other than that we've also
seen protests in the northeast of India
massive protests today they also turned
violent we witness scenes of protesters
chanting slogans around a bonfire the
police reacted they shot her teargas
shells at them we've also learned that
the Indian Army is on standby in Assam
one column that 70 soldiers all stand by
in the state of Assam and two columns of
Indian soldiers at 140 soldiers on
standby in Tripura we're also we've seen
protests these people however are
protesting for different reasons they're
saying they don't want any migrants to
be given Indian citizenship whether
Hindus all Muslims because they want to
protect their indigenous culture and
their livelihood northeast of India has
had a long history of opposition to
Bengalis especially those who originally
are from Bangladesh and shall thank you
for that for now that is until war with
all the latest on that breaking news
from India thank you